[Música]
hablamos de salud en directo a mary que
ya está conmigo preparada lista en el
estudio más romeros a la mar bienvenida
feliz martes es para ti empezamos con la
noticia de última hora acaba de salir
hace minutos fisher va a permitir que
otras farmacéuticas creen versiones
genéricas de su pintura contra el coi 19
qué buena noticia mala si es una buena
noticia es un paso hacia una
distribución más equitativa de este tipo
de medicamentos y eso es gracias a un
acuerdo con el fondo común de patentes
de medicamentos de escuchemos antes que
todo el anuncio que hicieron
en el fondo común de patentes de
medicamentos creados por la agencia de
salud de united para aumentar el acceso
a medicinas en países de ingresos bajos
y medianos anuncia un acuerdo voluntario
de licencia del candidato a tratamiento
oral antiviral de facer contra el kobe
19 que se administra con una dosis baja
de britton a virus
recordemos que es un acuerdo que
entonces lo que hace es permitir que
otros fabricantes hagan versiones
genéricas de esta pastilla y eso hace
más accesible más barata también más
fácil de fabricar una herramienta que se
prevé que que vaya a ser clave en la
lucha contra el kobe 19 el acuerdo
incluye y cinco países que representan
aproximadamente la mitad de la población
del planeta y también pues para recordar
un poco cómo era este medicamento se
dice según los primeros estudios que
podría evitar en más de un 80 por ciento
los casos de kobe grave en personas con
riesgos ya preexistentes
merck que está desarrollando una
pastilla similar y que de hecho un
poquito más avanzada que facer en el
desarrollo de este fármaco a tener un
acuerdo parecido con el mismo fondo y
pues en ambos casos supone un paso
adelante hacia esta distribución más
equitativa de los medicamentos sobre
todo después de que haya habido tantas
críticas por la inequidad que ha tenido
la llegada de las vacunas a todo el
mundo recordemos no es una liberación de
patentes no es lo mismo que es lo que
reclaman algunos son algunas entidades
sociales pero es un paso a es un paso
adelante así es mal pero seguimos
hablando de kobe 19 la vacuna contra el
virus desarrollada en españa sigue
avanzando le pregunto cuáles son estas
novedades pues básicamente paso a la
fase dos de los estudios lo aprobó la
agencia española de medicamentos y
productos sanitarios y lo anunció el
presidente del gobierno español pedro
sánchez escuchamos lo
segunda fase que se va a llevar a cabo
en diez centros hospitalarios y con más
de 1000 voluntarios pues va a contar con
una ayuda de 15 millones de euros del
gobierno de españa tal y como aprobamos
hace dos semanas en el consejo de
ministros pero creo que esta es una
extraordinaria noticia para la ciencia
para la sociedad española y que
demuestra que efectivamente españa se
puede situar porque no a la vanguardia
también en la respuesta frente al cob y
como hemos hecho también en otros muchos
ámbitos
repasemos igualmente qué sabemos de esta
vacuna al día de hoy es una vacuna
desarrollada con la tecnología de
proteína recombinante que eso consiste
básicamente en unas proteínas de
los virus de ccoo bit 19 además de un
refuerzo para fortalecer la respuesta
inmunológica y eso hace que el cuerpo
pueda reconocer a esas proteínas del
virus y reaccionar cuando se contagie es
la misma tecnología usada por ejemplo
por novavax que es la de la farmacéutica
estadounidense el fármaco se conserva
entre los 2 y los 8 grados eso hace
también augura una distribución
logística mucho más fácil los ensayos
clínicos se han hecho administrando dos
dosis con 21 días de diferencia y la
empresa quiere empezar a distribuir ya
el fármaco a principios del 2022 y dice
que va a tener 600 millones de dosis
listos para distribuir durante todo el
año próximo este estudio además se dará
en personas que ya hayan recibido dos
dosis de vacunas facer es decir que se
estudiará como dosis de refuerzo para
personas que ya hayan sido inmunizadas
recordemos además que españa tiene el 80
por ciento más de hecho de su población
vacunada con lo que puede ser incluso
más práctico saber qué efectos tiene
como como dosis de refuerzo que como
vacuna inicial ahora mismo así es marc
pero seguimos hablando de otro virus que
también alerta a la comunidad científica
internacional estamos hablando de casos
de gripe aviar que se han quitado en
varios países de europa y también de
asia pues se han empezado a sonar las
alarmas los epidemiólogos están
revisando que pasa la gripe aviar es una
enfermedad que afecta principalmente a
los pájaros pero que puede pasar a los
humanos estos son los países que han
detectado algún tipo de alerta francia
países bajos y bélgica han tomado ya
algunas medidas de contención al
detectar casos aislados noruega japón
corea del sur han tenido ya lo que ha
llamado brotes en algunas granjas aviar
es mientras que china es el 1 ahora que
ya ha detectado casos en humanos son 21
en casos en lo que vamos de 2020 21 eso
es cuatro veces más de los que se
detectaron en 2020 y entre esos casos ha
habido seis muertes este virus no pasa
tan fácilmente entre entre pájaros y
humanos recordemos que no pasa por
ejemplo por comer la carne o por comer
los huevos de un pájaro infectado sino
con un contacto muy estrecho por ejemplo
tomando agua que haya sido contaminada
por ahora no es un caso de epidemia pero
históricamente sabemos que si puede ser
un caso grave de crisis de salud pública
entonces pues tocará estar pendientes y
que haya una vigilancia epidemiológica
sólida terminamos en afganistán gobierno
de los talibanes criticó la comunidad
internacional por cortar la ayuda que
sostenía el sistema de salud pues si
después de haber hablado de afganistán
varias veces en este espacio finalmente
el ministro de salud interino de
afganistán habló para criticar tanto al
gobierno anterior como a la comunidad
internacional escuchemos lo
sector durante 20 años el sector de la
salud se ha mantenido dependiente de la
ayuda externa no se ha hecho ningún
trabajo para prepararse en caso de que
ese sistema fallara para que la
infraestructura y los recursos de
atención a la salud pudieran sobrevivir
cómo podemos proveer servicios y los
recursos extranjeros se restringen y las
organizaciones internacionales cortan su
ayuda el banco mundial la unión europea
usa y no cumplen las promesas que le
hicieron los afganos me lanzara la mano
las tardar lo del
recordemos que realmente afganistán
atraviesa una crisis de salud grave
actualmente hay 32 millones de niños
menores de 5 años en riesgo de
desnutrición múltiples hospitales han
tenido que cerrar pero la verdad es que
no es del todo cierto que no haya habido
ningún tipo de ayuda internacional por
ejemplo la onu ha asegurado ya que
pagará los salarios de 25.000
trabajadores que llevan meses trabajando
sin cobrar cosa que también ha
dificultado mucho la atención pública en
afganistán es decir que si ha habido un
recorte de ayudas pero no es del todo
cierto que no estén llegando en ningún
tipo de dinero pues al sistema público
afgano marc gracias por toda la
información entonces ahora sí vamos con
nuestro segundo invitado del día y lo
bueno es que usted se vacunó puede tener
su carnet de vacunación para entrar a
los restaurantes aquí en asia a dudas te
levante las alas y que le invito a que
me acompañe